on va parler c'est moi qui a choisi ce
sujet aujourd'hui ah personnellement euh
c'est mon ami Moulou qui m'a parlé de ça
parce qu'il connaitt voilà il m'a dit
que c'était un truc de fou en ce moment
on va parler d'un sujet qui est en train
donc de prendre une ampleur inédite
c'est un traitement contre le diabète
ayant comme effet secondaire une perte
de poids assez significative et il y a
de plus en plus de gens c'est utilisé
illégalement par des personnes cherchant
à perdre des kilos car ses effets sont
vantés sur les réseaux sociaux par des
influenceurs sont des piqûes et c'est
vrai qu'il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui font ça et cette nouvelle patrique
pratique n'est pas sans conséquence sur
la santé on va vous expliquer tout ça et
il y a syidneyana qui va venir nous en
est nous en parler dans un instant ça
c'est devenu un truc de fou je vous le
dis et il y a de nombreux stars qui le
font également et c'est extrêmement
dangereux je vous le dis il faut pas le
faire euh voilà j'espère que personne ne
le fait ici non mais on en connaî non
c'est vrai vous en connaissez aussi a
des cègues moi on Fa pas en tout cas on
connait oui personne oui tous là on
connait des on connait la même personne
qu' l'a fait c'est vrai moi je la
connais moi oui he envoyz le sujet il v
me dire de qui s'agit ok c'est la
nouvelle tendance sur le réseau social
TikTok jusqu'à - 15 kg en 2 mois aux
ampi un médicament délivré sur
ordonnance destiné aux personnes
diabétiques à cause de son effet coupfin
il est présenté comme un produit miracle
pour la perte de poids dans cette
pharmacie la demande a doublé en 2 ans
le l'osampique n'est pas disponible
aujourd'hui il ne parvient pas toujours
à le délivrer aux patients diabétiques
la prise de ce médicament sans
encadrement peut avoir de nombreuses
conséquences sur la santé l'Agence du
Médicament lance l'alerte et demande aux
professionnels de santé d'être
vigilant sidne Anana est avec nous merci
Sidney d'être avec nous avant qu'on
parle de ce fléo j'imis qu'on parle d'un
autre s'il vous plaît vous croyez chez
vos mères ou quoi je vrais qu'on parle
d'un autre fléo les chéris euh c'est
l'éternuement qui a éternué on a les
images je ne sais pas je les découvre
avec vous euh je vais voir qui a éternué
depuis plusieurs jours euh la raison la
professeur a montré
une discret c'est qui elle est trop
mignonne vas-y c'est pas
moi alors ça fait longtemps que j'ai ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu de Me Val
ça ça va elle reste digne he ouais c'est
grave hein reste Valérie a range ses
fiches du coup elle accuse jacqu en plus
elle sait très bien ce qu'elle a fait
bah oui prof profz menti là j'avoue j'ai
pas de réparti là je je me sens toute
bête désolé pardon il y aura des
sanctions
chef il y en aura malheureusement oui il
en aura non mais dites que c'est vous la
prochaine fois c'est pas grave oui
pardon mais pour moi c'est et je voulais
que je vous dise pour moi c'est Jacques
[Rires]
je vois pas
moi je vois pas Kelly désolé désolé
c'est inadmissible franchement non mais
on notera l'élégance de Jacques qui
quand même à la fin fini par s'accuser
luiême franchement il est gentil he il
il est gentil il est gentil mon Jaco euh
alors bonsoir Sid voilà on on était sur
une affaire voilà qui est importante
plus haute importance exactement donc
diabète autour des picures contre euh
c'est ces piqû pour le diabète pour pour
maigrir et c'est vrai que ça il y a de
plus en plus de gens qui le font c'est
un truc de fou et est-ce qu'on vous
est-ce que vous étiez au courant de
cette histoire d'abord Cyr bonsoir merci
de m'inviter et puis toutes mes excuses
j'ai même pas eu le temps de me changer
sors du bloc je suis en
retard MZ appelé il y a 1 heure et je
suis là merci comme
c'estj c'est un sujet qui me paraît très
important je tenais à être ici et je ne
tiendrai pas une langue de bois très
bien je vais être clair et ainsi cisive
sur un problème de santé publique je
voudrais vous rappeler un mot qui vous
trône à l'oreille le Médiator ah ouais
est-ce que vous savez que le Médiator
que nous avons même scandale
prescrit parce que on nous a conseillé
de le prescrire entraîné beaucoup de
morts je voudrais que cette fois-ci on
prenne un peu de recul par rapport à
cette mode d'un
nouvelle d' nouvelle
molécule dont on considère que c'est une
révolution à l'origine on a découvert un
traitement pour le diabète et c'est
quand même tellement de diabétique que
ça rend
service maintenant on se rend compte que
ça peut servir aussi pour faire maigrir
un certain nombre de
personnes malheureusement et là je sais
que je vais me faire plein plein plein
d'ennemis ah et je n'ai pas peur à mon
âge de me faire des
ennemis je vais agresser les
influenceuses ah ouais oui bravo les
influenceuses se sont emparés de ce
segment en se disant voilà encore un
créneau excusez-moi s'il y a des
influenceurs ici présente
si carose on a les
influenceuses se sont servies de ce
nouveau médicament d'une nouvelle forme
de ce médicament atténué le ligovi pour
dire on peut maigrir avec cela sans
tenir compte de tous les effets
secondaires d'un médicament elles ne
sont pas médecins si était médecin cela
se saurait elles font leur métier chacun
est libre de faire son métier mais les
effets secondaires je ne les J jamais vu
ni lu dans leur correspondance et dans
leur poste or c'est un médicament qui
entraî des problèmes cardiovasculaires
Ahou c'est un médicament qui entraîne
des problèmes
thyroïdiens certes il y a des pertes de
poids mais à quel prix on doit perdre du
poids voilà c'est ma question quand une
influenceuse communique en disant j'ai
perdu 4 kg avec ce médicament nous n en
tant que médecin et moi en tant que
chirurgien à qui beaucoup de
paions s'adresse pour me dire est-ce que
vous pouvez me prescrire ce médicament
quand je refuse de les opérer parce que
elles ont un surpoids et que je leur
demande de maigrir avant de faire une
hypoaspiration maigrir ça veut dire quoi
un effort de nutrition de diététiique un
effort d'exercice physique si elles font
pas tout cela à quel titre moi en tant
que chirurgien je dois aller dans leur
sens ça n'a aucun sens si je faisais ça
j'estime que c'est criminel de ma part
donc je leur demande d'abord de faire
des efforts avant de passer à des
médicaments qui ont des effets
secondaires quand on a 30 40 kg de trop
quand on veut éviter une Slieve c'est
une opération chirurgicale que tout le
monde doit connaître et qu'on veut
passer à la sleeve médicale c'estàdire
ce traitement l'mique avec des effets
secondaires que vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer don des suicide des tentatives
de suicide il faut arrêter de parler
comme si on avait découvert la molécule
miracle et c'est pas parce que cette
société danoise est passée au premier
plan devant toutes les sociétés du CAC
40 qu'on va tous tomber dans ce piège
pourquoi la société c'est qu si on tombe
dans ce piège on est juste encore d'une
très grande naïveté je peux me faire
insulter par les influenceuses je veux
faire détruire par un certain nombre de
médecins qui préent cela je refuse moi
de prescrire ce médicament parce que on
va retomber dans le problème du Médiator
maintenant je suis à votre écoute je
réponds à toutes les questions parce que
je connais le sujet très préc une
question de Valérie Benaim de
Casablanca de Casa magazine moi par
exemple je connais quelqu'un de très
proche qui en prend pour des raisons
médicales parce que il est atteint de
diabète mais justement il se retrouve
parfois en pénurie parce que parce que
des médecins qui sont pas scrupuleux
prescrivent ce ce médicament pour des
gens qui n'en ont pas besoin et ceux qui
en ont réellement besoin quand ils
arrivent à la pharmacie il n'y en a plus
il y a un début de pénurie pour ce pour
et le pharmacien doit prévenir en disant
il il m' il il me reste en stock il y a
un souci aussi de la part des médecins
qui qui merci de me tendre perche ah
écoutez-moi nous sommes en pénurie d'un
médicament pour des diabétiques de type
2 nous sommes en pénurie pénu dans
quelques mois ou années je sais pas on
arrivera à combler ce déficit de
fabrication pénurie pourquoi parce que
et encore une fois les influenceuses
vont me détruire parce que à la suite
des influenceuses des médecins sont
appelés à prescrire ce médicament au
détriment des diabétiques de type 2 or
un diabétique de type 2 il en va de sa
survie de ses problèmes
cardioovvasculaires de ses problèmes de
vue et on est en déficit à cause de cela
donc je suis là j'ai accepté de venir à
brûle pour point quand on m'app il y a
une heure BL juste pour dénoncer ce
problème vous avez fini là vous a fini
le patient
quandme
pardon il est soigné le patient c'est
bon il est pas vousz refermé non mais il
faut dire aux jeunes femmes et aux
jeunes filles que par je vous parais
excusez-moi je vous présente excus si je
vous parais si tendu sur ce sujet c'est
que c'est un sujet de santé publique je
vous prie ne prenez pas ce sujet à la
légère il y a des diabétiques qui n'ont
pas de traitement parce qu'il y a des
influenceuse qui veut perdre 4 kg est-ce
que vous avez des questions les Chéries
autour de la table ou est-ce que vous
avez rien à dire et vous voulez rentrer
chez vous oui ver vous parlez de
médiator le scandale du Médiator il y a
eu des morts là on entend des effets
secondaire qui ser par exemple problème
de thyroïde ou nausé vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir des morts à cause de ces
piqures alors pour l'instant on a des
pancréatit ouais sur ces pancréatites il
y a eu aucun mort qu'on soit très clair
mais on est que en phase 3 de l'étude
quand on passera au phase 4 où tout le
monde nous rapportera les effets
secondaires on peut découvrir davantage
autant je considère que en fonction de
l'obésité qui entraîne beaucoup de morts
on peut prendre ce risque de l'Que
autant simplement pour une surcharge
pondérale de 4 ou 5 kg pour ne pas faire
un régime diététique et du sport je
considère que c'est
inacceptable peut pas prendre le risque
de problème thyroïde de pancréati de
nausé et de quelqu fois des tent
suicidair
oui oui docteur mon voisin de droite m'a
dit ah c'est génial je vais faire ce
traitement parce que je veux perdre 11
kg est-ce que vous pouvez u s' vous
plaît je pense qu'une seule chose il
faut le sortir de
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'émission des ouf il y a que des ouf
les gens quand ils arrivent ils sont pas
ouf
vient tu'oule pas m'en voulez pas ça
veut dire que vous avez rien compris à
mon discours puis vous il a pas sa place
ici la mort
JeanMichel oui docteur est-ce que c'est
pas vousz piqué mon téléphone parce que
je le trouve
plus
Kelly je trouve qu'on ne parle pas assez
de de ces médecins justement qui
prescrivent ce genre de médicamenten
donc qui sont-ils où sont-ils et
qu'est-ce qu'il risque c'est pour ça
écoutez-moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
dénoncé il faut les des influenceuses
parce que vous con M m qui av voit une
patiente il envoit 10 20 30 par jour ils
sont débordés et elles ont vu un
influenceuse j'ai vu ce médicament vgovi
je veux mécrer tout malheureusement
certains médecins
par facilité par fatigue peuvent être
amenés à préscrire ça je dénonce non pas
le médecin je dénonce sa fatigue ils
sont débordés fatigués et ils sont
influencés par les influenceuses
négatives je sais que tous mes propos
vont être dénoncés par tout le monde
demain c'est pas un problème je je ne
suis pas là pour
tenirair a des effet secondair dans
quelques années on va compter le nombre
de morts donc le médecin doit savoir
dire nous de manière naturelle on a
quand même envie d'un petit peu
incriminer les médecins qui prescrivent
ces chosesl qui ne sont pas adapté à
leur patient quand
même un un petit peu non je peux pas
critiquer votre répon pas peux pas peux
pas oui patri non aux États-Unis c'est
la folie tous les à Hollywood il y a les
acteurs qui utilisent ça de manière
complètement folle et H
oui on est c'est un peu un mot que j'ai
pas osé utiliser sombre dans une forme
d'hystérie et ça coûte combien
c'estàdire que si on est diabétique je
comprends
mais oui mais si on n pas diabétique on
veut juste perdre 4 kg non ça coûte
beaucoup à la SCU c'est remboursé c'est
un drame mais pardon moi je crois qu'on
rentre dans un drame social et de santé
publique certes perd du poids est un
bienfait pour tout le monde sur le plan
de l'hygiène de vie certes réduire de 20
à 30 kg
l'obésité% donne des années de survie ça
va éviter des sleeves chirurgicales une
sleeve chirurgicale ça veut dire une
réduction de
l'estomac en opposition avec une sleeve
médicale qui est ce nouveau traitement
mais il faut peser avant de prendre ce
genre de décision tous les effets
néfaste qui en phase 4 ne sont pas
encore évalué voilà ok comment un
médecin peut prescrire alors que il
s'agit d'un médicament pour lutter
contre le diabète alors si quelqu'un
arrive dansas dit c'est la
fatigue presque pass là excusez-moi il y
a deux médicaments différents le
médicament du diabète 2 qu'ils ont le
droit de prescrire et un médicament
extrêmement atténué qui en vogue et qui
est propulsé par les RA réseaux sociaux
et c'est le 10è de la dose et qui perd
quelques kilos mais dont on ne parle pas
des effets néfaste et secondairire j'ai
vu des patientes qui sont venu me voir
m'ont dit voulez pas m'opérer donc je
vais prendre tel médicament parce que
voulez pas m'opérer et après vous
pourrez m'opérer si j'ai trop de poids
ils ont fait des tentatives de suicide
entreetemps quand ell sontevenu me voir
elle m'a raconté les effets néfastes de
ces médicaments on ne doit pas les
oblitérer dans notre cerveau il est
urgent de ne pas prendre de décisions
attive point merci merci syney oui
rienis désolé d'avoir été aussi
catégorique ne m'en veut pas c ne m'en
veut pas jamais au contraire je suis
très content de te voir qu'est-ce qui se
passe il a été parfait été
parfait si tu voulais que je tienne un
discoursdé pas là pour de bois on rentre
dedans risqu on prend des risques on pas
peur de dire shit merci merci d'avoir
été avec nous les deux vous allez sortir
mais j'ai rien dit j'ai rien fait le
plus de question c'est vrai c'est vrai
j'avoue merci en tout cas merci Sid et
vous revenez quand vous voulez y a un
patient qui vous attend pourer faut le
refermer les
Mecar il est merci si n'est qu' un amour
il est venu pour nous les gars il là il
est en tenu de il part direct à la B
j'ai pas eu le temps de me changer ne
m'en voulez pas et n'oubliez pas que
pour ceux qui ont vu la télé ces
jours-ci que je rentre d'une mission de
soutien en Israël dans les hôpitaux et à
Gaza qui m'a beaucoup heuré on en
parlera un jour merci d'avoir été avec
nous en tout cas de nous avir parlé de
la sleeve également euh